the first time before in love your
submental but it's very difficult to
recall anything isn't it
nicolas holds and kristen stewart fall
in love in their new movie equals out
now and the stars are revealing what
they've learned from their real-life
relationships as you guys have grown up
in the spotlight now of your ideas about
love and relationships changed or
shifted or or have a i don't think mine
have particularly changed too much i
think you just grow up and you become
more aware of yourself and other people
and then and then that changes it a
little bit Kristine's most high-profile
relationship was with her Twilight
co-star Robert Pattinson and Nicolas
famously dated Jennifer Lawrence
maybe I expectations low a little bit
your expectations lower you're like I
need to scale down in terms of what I'm
thinking of expectations love has
lowered now I'm gonna find my soul mate
I'm gonna find my equals bar has been
lowered yeah the stars pulled from their
first personal experiences with love for
this movie you just like place yourself
in that feeling you know that maybe
you've had before it's it's like the
most visceral intense overwhelming
feeling I feel like the biggest theme in
this movie is that you can't change the
way that you feel about someone you
agree do you believe in soulmates yes I
agree completely pop I don't I don't
think anyone can change the way they
feel should have to depending on what
they feel extremist thoughts probably
you can kind of control how you feel I
guess like I mean to a degree but the
worst is if you're feeling a certain way
and you're just like I can't make you
feel I can't stay away I can't not be
around
realize what would happen if